so much and it's like they don't have
like Insurance working on because like
[__] you at home anyone help me I'm
loving this by the way I'm sorry I'm
just really excited after shocking fans
with that erratic Instagram Live Love is
Blind Alum Shane Jansen says he's taking
a break from social media oh God Shane
who appeared on season two of the hit
Netflix dating series as well as the
reality spin-off perfect match had fans
worried after he appeared disheveled on
Instagram last week
first of all man I have no friends all
right that's my home alone right I
thought I had friends but you know
nobody invites anymore anywhere
One account posted a clip of the live to
tick tock asking anyone else concerned
about Shane
questions no questions anyone let's go
spill awesome
several fans agreed in the comments and
shortly after Shane announced he's
taking a breather posting this message
to his insta story everyone loves a
scandal I'll see y'all next week or
month and
we're gonna leave it at that this all
comes after much speculation Shane
abused drugs while filming for Netflix
people thought I was doing cocaine I
miked up the whole time everyone would
have heard me do it like it's wild to
think that I was carrying cocaine on me
like and I was just snorting lines and I
was doing all this kind of stuff in the
bathroom when I mugged up like they can
literally hear you Whispering every word
you do they hear and like how could they
not hear me just do that fans of the
show will recall Shane got engaged to
Natalie Lee on their season when I
walking down that Hall and I saw Natalie
everything's just sweating like crazy
I'm like I gotta kiss her right away
before I start sweating all over her
face from the very beginning especially
towards our the you know our our dates
in the pods you know I really felt like
I I could see
him as my husband but Natalie rejected
him at the altar after the two had a
dramatic off-camera fight right before
their wedding day
Michelle
I love you when you're still my customer
really big issues to sort through
I know that night definitely solidified
why it didn't work out I mean it led up
to a few things before that and I think
that's why it blew up at that time
they've since had multiple public spats
rekindling and ending their romance
several times since the Show wrapped in
2021 oh there is absolutely still hope
for me now for what we had was real well
we have a special I love her so care
about her
the door is always open for sure I think
regardless of you know what our outcomes
were we all fell in love in those pods
and so I think in that way like Love is
Blind you could really fall in love with
the core of who someone is then this
year Shane was one of three finalist
couples on perfect match partnering up
with too hot to handle and the circle
Alum Chloe Beach I think by far we are
one of the most compatible couples in
the house yeah but the two ended their
relationship shortly after filming
wrapped
foreign